let's talk about what's going on
guatemala we got this story from the new
york post
guatemala's president blames biden for
border crisis as
protesters tell kamala harris that trump
won
this is this is amazing these photos go
home come
go home kamala mind your own business
and a big sign that says commonwealth
trump won
that that is crazy i didn't expect this
i would have thought
i actually no i take that back this
makes a whole lot of sense the people
who are
staying in guatemala probably like what
trump's policies are towards you know
guatemala and
what they should and shouldn't be doing
the people who are leaving guatemala
they're not going to like trump right
that makes sense yeah
because trump's the guy is blocking them
from trying to get into the u.s so
naturally the people who remain are like
yeah go trump
well and you you sort of touched on this
earlier but the messaging that the biden
administration is sending to people who
might be considering migrating to the us
is so
mixed like kamala goes down there and
she says if you're if you're thinking of
coming here illegally don't even try it
because you will not be
welcome if you're one of the illegal
immigrants who's already here one of the
11 million plus we're already here you
know you're going to be naturalized
and we're going to give you citizenship
because there needs to be a path for
citizenship because anything else would
be inhumane
but you're not welcome to come here if
you're not here it's insane
this is one of the biggest problems of
this administration okay because because
i want to do that check do we have biden
derangement syndrome no
yeah no we don't check it out dallas
news reports vp harris in guatemala says
border visit would be mere grand
gesture warns migrants do not come okay
come on i mean yeah look maybe
gesture fine whatever trump went down
and surveyed a lot of the border
it was a it was a big issue he knows the
american people were concerned about he
went
i think about this like you know trump
derangement syndrome or abundant
arrangement syndrome thing and i'm like
i
honestly i think it really does in many
ways come down to a difference in
opinion based on
what is what deserves priority
and so i think there's a lot of people
who are like liberals leftists
mostly liberals leftists at your
different space liberals who are just
like
i don't care all that much about illegal
immigration i just don't
and so republicans do and then the left
is like why aren't you talking about
january 6 and republicans don't they're
like because it was a right
so it really is like a difference of
opinion that there there's no
obviously in media there's a lot of fact
based problems where the left or the
right believe different things
but i think a lot of it's just
subjective morality i don't think
january 6 was the apocalypse i think it
was a right i think it was bad
i think it was you know it was serious
but not the apocalypse like they're
playing out to be what did anderson
cooper say
you see what he said oh well uh no no i
i was saying the worst
attack on this country since 9 11 oh
civil war wow that is hardcore
wow jfk getting assassinated sure but i
mean so
i hear what you say about people putting
different emphasis on different issues
based on where they are
in the political spectrum but the biden
administration's
messaging on this has been very confused
sometimes they're saying things that are
very like warm and friendly and open to
people who want to come here and then
other times it's well you're not welcome
so like
biden putting a moratorium on
deportations
and then kamala going down and saying
illegal immigrants are not welcome here
to me seems
ridiculously conflicting regardless of
how you feel about illegal immigration
as an issue
it's a fun house mirror of policy
because early on in his campaign and
even you know
biden got blocked from doing this but
biden was like we're gonna put a
moratorium on deportations come on man
and then you know he gets in and he now
now they've officially ended as of june
1st the remaining mexico policy
which was donald trump's policy that
said if you come to the border
we'll process your asylum while you
remain in mexico so they officially
ended that now they're doing catch and
release
so people are they're once again
encouraging people to come in
they catch them let them go in fact joe
biden his administration has been
smuggling migrant children into
different states in the dead of night
which is one of the creepiest things
i've ever heard things now
here's the funhouse mirror because now
kamala harris says do not come right
that's funny like a week ago biden
announced he was increasing the amount
of refugees and asylums they would allow
into the united states
so biden's like we're going to increase
the amount of people that we allow in
and then common goes but don't come
yeah exactly they're gonna be like nah
i'll come and biden's gonna let me in
what
that's the thing this is sort of what i
was touching on a little bit earlier i
don't know if i articulated it quite
well enough but
to say we need to naturalize all of the
illegal immigrants who are
already here but then turn around and
say
none of you should cross the border
though to me is completely pointless of
course they're going to come over here
like what are you saying
you're you're welcoming them you're
inviting them even if not with your
words with then with your actions
but i kind of feel like that's part of
it you know kamala harris can go she
won't go to the border
all right that's serious that she's
showing she's not serious
right it's just a gesture tim right it's
it's not a priority for her
and that's what i was saying like i
think a lot of democrats are just like
who cares i think people like kamala
she's thinking about is this going to
get me votes the answer is
no because the democratic base they were
the ones that want to open borders
they were the ones that on the debate
stage that the moderator i remember was
how many of you are in favor
of giving universal health care to
illegal immigrants or legally and they
all raise their hand
my favorite as a democrats who like kind
of look around like is this what we're
about now they're like really
okay all right guys i guess yeah so so i
think kamala's just like i don't care
it's like i know some people are
bothered by it so i gotta say something
but she's not gonna say much
meanwhile the actual policies are making
the problem worse
and uh oh yeah this is crazy uh lady
just pulled this up the denver gazette
republican wins mayoral race in majority
hispanic mcallen texas
mcallen is where they expanded the
detention center they have kids sleeping
in dirt
big issues so i if you look at south
texas if you look at miami dude remember
uh during the 2020 election there was a
safe blue district in miami
flipped red yeah that was that was crazy
it's because
what did this guy say he said something
about communism was being bad
i don't know maybe it wasn't this guy
but these areas
like south texas majority hispanic they
do not like illegal immigration
and i have to imagine this because a lot
of these hard-working americans people
who came here illegally
are working and they're seeing what's
happening
is correct i actually had a friend who
came from chihuahua and she told me that
her parents told
her that she was going to do it legally
so that people would respect her
she did not like illegal immigrants
she's like they just come here it's easy
for them they get everything they want i
worked so hard and they're just taking
advantage of this system and it's it's
literally the system i'm now paying into
it's not there
i would imagine i don't know for sure
but like if you're in a big city
the illegal immigrants that are there
are already kind of assimilated like
they have jobs sort of but the ones on
the border are like
random people that just got over here
maybe don't even have any intention of
going to a city to get work
they just want to avoid the the chaos of
south africa i don't know
biden's been sending migrant kids in the
dead of night to various
states yeah they're they're they're
shipping uh these illegal immigrants
into like ohio
and then having them detained by the
local police they're like oh
we we detained these these illegal these
illegal immigrants so we need the police
you know in ohio to hold them
then once they get them say okay cut
them loose and they release them
directly into their community it's
spreading them out all across the
country
it is the weirdest the weirdest thing
now i have a question though in in the
story about kamala and like the
protesters
who's the racist one oh man that's rough
okay well here's what we'd have to
figure out tim we need to do
an analysis on the crowd and figure out
how many are men and how many are women
because kamal is a woman of color
right if most of the people in the crowd
are women to the point where you could
say the crowd is represented by women
then it
it's kind of a toss-up but if the crowd
is mostly male
in fact it doesn't even matter right if
there's any men in the crowd then the
crowd is somewhat male so
kamala has to be the victim here no
based on the rules of intersectionality
you've got math planned for this
exactly i know what's up yeah so no but
but
i guess the serious question is like i
think one of the reasons you're not
going to see this story
prominently on the left is just that it
makes no sense for the narrative
like a third world country or however
they would describe it minority country
saying they like trump better oh mcallen
texas they flip they flip republican
south texas district miami flip trump
flip trump guatemala we like trump
better
yeah i'm not saying everybody in
guatemala likes trump better
but it's it's he's going to run there
he's like going
about then he it president of guatemala
just takes over the united states
what dude it's trump
because i i could do it i get the job
done
if anyone could it's him he just 100
approval in guatemala and then
annexes the neighboring countries he
starts neighboring countries until he
gets the united states
i could see trump just going for it
right from guatemala he's like we could
we're good
i don't i don't know uh what the average
worker is supposed to think about this
kind of uh this kind of thing
i i love that uh people around the world
are
are invested in the politics of the
united states to the point where they're
gonna complain
i mean that's so that's awesome to me
this is global this is way beyond i mean
kindness i kind of like when people
aren't that invested in our politics and
don't comment on it if i'm completely
honest
yeah like why none why not why is it
that
so many places around the world are
obsessed with america i think because of
hollywood they hate us because they
ain't us
we got like the cultural hub of the
world in hollywood we have the fiscal
um not really the kind of the fiscal hub
of the world with the u.s federal
reserve in the us dollar that's kind of
the bank of england i mean we have the
federal we have the world reserve
currency swiss bank it's kind of coming
out of switzerland but we're like the
spearhead
so the world looks at us as like the
financial centerpiece and the cultural
centerpiece
not us necessarily but this country i
think it's movies
it gives that when you look at what when
you look at what hollywood is churning
out i get why the world hates us
it's like you understand i don't even
think it's our foreign policy i really
think it's all
i'm being facetious here no no it's like
in that vox article from uh i think it
was a year ago or two years ago
yeah i think it was two years ago now
where they they asked one of the
migrants in the caravan why they were
coming to america and the guy said i
miss buffalo wild wings yeah
i'm like buffalo wild wings is like
there's a bunch in mexico you know like
these people yeah the restaurant i mean
i love b-dubs too it's just not as good
there though can't remember less i don't
know oh b-dubs
is bw threes is buffalo wild wings
buffalo wild wings i didn't know that's
what bw stood for
b-dubs yeah bw threes what is that that
was a b-w
to the third power like i don't know
threes it was in ohio buffalo wild wings
get it it's only yeah
double w's yeah b-dubs come on bro
you never had a wild one have you ever
you've never had buffalo wild wings
i don't think you're talking about the
same thing you're talking about buffalo
sauce which is
french red hot and that's like the
secret ingredient buffalo wild sausage
anyway dude yeah you're talking about a
restaurant yes i'm talking about these
people who are walking through mexico
and the reporter is like why are you
walk why won't you stay in mexico and
the guy's like i miss buffalo wild wings
and i'm like dude it's right there in
mexico city i went there
no no joke i went to the mexico city
buffalo wildlife it was great
it's wonderful i mean this is like
honestly
like why are you going back to chicago
i've missed portillos
i didn't go to chicago for that but you
order it you ordered it man it's
fantastic true that's why i come here
someone someone in the audience asked if
i was kidnapped actually tim just has
portillos
no but i think when it comes to these
migrants they're they're watching
american tv commercials movies
and so their whole perception of reality
is based upon american cities
and stuff you see like youtubers this is
also a great place to live
it is it's awesome in many ways i mean
it's going downhill unfortunately
especially with the kind of thing the
kinds of things we've been tolerating
over the past year and a half
particularly though those are probably
more of a symptom of the issues we've
been tolerating for much longer than
that but
yeah america is a great place okay yeah
we got beat ups we've got buffalo wild
wings
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members
only content segments you can't get
anywhere else go to timcast.com become a
member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you